بعد أكثر من عامين، عاد
كلا رأسه إلى الخلف وهو على استعداد لقلب رأسه في
حديقة حيوان كاميرون بارك في واكو بولاية تكساس. هل يتفق
الرأسان ويكاد يتجاهل
كل منهما الآخر، يلتقي بانشو وليفتي
على اسم الأغنية الريفية الغربية هانتر
يحتاج إلى صلواتك، هذا صحيح ولكن احفظه.  تم
العثور على ثعبان الجرذ الغربي غير المؤذي من قبل أحد السكان المحليين
وتم التبرع به لحديقة الحيوان عندما كان
عمره بضعة أسابيع، كان لديه عقلين مختلفين في
سبع سنوات، وقد نما من ثماني بوصات
إلى ثلاثة أقدام هل هو يمين الرأس  أم أنه
يرأس رأسه الأيسر،
فالرأس المهيمن هو الرأس الأيمن
ولكن الرأس الأيسر لديه أفكار خاصة
به وعندما يذهب اليسار في
اتجاه واحد ويذهب بونشو في الاتجاه الآخر، فمن
المشكلة أن يعلق الثعبان على الأشياء
ويجرح نفسه في عام 2021،
حصل الجرح  من السيئ للغاية أنه كان لا بد من إزالته من
معرضه ليتم علاجه ولشفاء تلك
المادة الشمعية الموجودة على رقبة ليفتي
تحمي المنطقة المصابة، لذا أي رأس
يأكل
كلاهما يفعلان ذلك، لكن الحقوق المهيمنة
أحيانًا تسحب ليفتي بعيدًا عن
وجبة الفأر التي يحصل عليها الرأس الأيمن.  المزيد لتناول الطعام
على الرغم من أن كل ذلك ينتهي في نفس
المعدة منذ 20 عامًا، قمت بتغطية
سلحفاة ذات رأسين تدعى Lefty Righty،
والتي سرق رأسها الطعام من بعضها البعض
عندما تثاءب أحدهما وفعل الآخر أيضًا، وقد تم
القبض عليهما في النباتات التي
تظهرها الثعابين.  تم تجديده بحيث لا يوجد
الكثير مما يمكن التعلق به، ولا يعد الرأسان
سببًا لعدم تمكن بانشو وليفتي من
الاستمتاع بالرومانسية بمجرد أن يكبر، فسوف
يتعارضان مع الأنثى صعودًا وهبوطًا في جسدها،
لذا ربما يكون الرأسان أفضل من رأس
واحد، فمن المؤكد أنه ممكن
الثلاثي الأفعى برأسين يكفي
أن تترك رأسك يدور
لقناة سي إن إن نيويورك